my concern my sole concern is what is
going to deliver a better consumer
experience in the digital age and I
truly believe that removing some of
these regulations that are impeding
ip-based investment and getting rid of
some of these antiquated regulations is
the best way to promote competition
promote consumer welfare not these over
the top you have 80 year old regulations
that have been proven not to work
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with FCC
Commissioner Ajit PI he is a proponent
of
an open Internet but not net neutrality
Ajit thanks for talking to us
nikka Dizz great to be with you recently
the FCC Chairman Tom wheeler said that
he's going to move forward with the FCC
regulating the internet under title 2
regulations and that will change the
regulatory structure from that of an
information service to a telecom what is
the most important thing that people
need to know about that switch I think
the most important thing that people
need to know is that this is a solution
that won't work to a problem that simply
doesn't exist let me take a lot of part
of that initially nowhere in the 332
page document that I've received will
anyone find the FCC detailing any kind
of systemic harm to consumers and it
seems to me that should be the predicate
for any preemptive regulation you know
some kind of systemic problem that
requires an industry-wide solution that
simply isn't here so I mean you're
saying the internet is not broken I
don't think it is no I think by and
large people are able to access the
lawful content of their choice and while
competition isn't where we want it to be
we can always have more choices better
speeds so lower prices etc nonetheless
if you look at the metrics compared to
say Europe which has a utility style
regulatory approach I think we're doing
pretty well
what can we say about how much you know
one of the things that people say well
we need to regulate the internet because
local ISP in our internet service
providers like Time Warner or Comcast or
what have you they have an effective
local monopoly on service is that
accurate and would that be enough of a
reason to say yeah we got to do
something I certainly think there are a
lot of markets where consumers want and
could use more competition that's why
since I become a commissioner I focused
on getting rid of some of the regulatory
underbrush that stands in the way of
some upstart competitors providing that
alternative streamlining local
permitting rules getting more wireless
infrastructure out there to give a
mobile alternative making sure we have
enough spectrum in the commercial
marketplace but these kinds of title to
common carrier regulations ironically
will count will be completely
counterproductive it's going to sweep a
lot of these smaller providers away they
simply don't have the ability to comply
with all these ring
relations and moreover it's going to
deter investment in broadband networks
and so ironically enough this
hypothetical problem that people are
worried about is going to become worse
because of the lack of competition but
you're also saying it doesn't exist so I
mean to most people in America have you
no choice in broadband carriers and do
they have more choice than they had say
five years ago and is there a reason to
believe that they'll have even more
choice in another five years I think
while there are hiccups that any given
consumer might experience in any given
market nonetheless if you look on the
aggregate Americans are much better off
than they were five years ago ten years
ago speeds are increasing the amount of
choice is increasing something like 76%
of Americans have access to three or
more facilities based providers it's
over 80 percent of Americans have access
to 25 megabit per second speeds in terms
of the mobile equation part of the
equation there's no question that
America has made in tremendous strides
eighty-six percent of Americans now have
access to 4G LTE we have fifty percent
of the world's LTE subscribers yet only
four percent of the population so now a
lot of people will say though that you
know part of the problem is that Europe
for instance is so much more advanced
than we are in terms of the the speed of
connectivity the price of a connection
and the variety is that just wrong that
is wrong if you look at the Akamai state
of the Internet report for example or
other objective data there's no question
that America is better off especially
considering a relatively lower
population density in terms of
deployment speeds prices whatever metric
you choose moreover if you look at
investment investment in the United
States is $562 per household in Europe
it's only two hundred forty four dollars
what why is that important I think it's
important because the key is we want to
have a strong enough platform for
innovation investment and online options
as possible but you won't get that if
the private sector doesn't have the
incentive to risk capital to build those
networks it's a pretty tough thing to
build the but you nuts and bolts of the
internet and if the regulatory system is
one that second-guesses you every single
step of the way regulates your rates
tells you what service plans are allowed
or not regulates the commercial
arrangements you have both with end
users and companies you're going to meet
a situation where you
we'll have the European situation I
don't know if he counts as your boss but
the head of the FCC you know says he's
Tom Wheeler says no we're going to place
the Internet under title two but we're
going to use a light touch and his
predecessor Julius Genachowski also
talked about that and we're going to do
a lot of forbearance what is the
forbearance process and how would it
actually work forbearance is a process
that was set up by Congress in 1996 to
allow the FCC not to enforce a
particular statute or regulation if it
determined that that statute or
regulation was no longer necessary to
enforce in the public interest and
essentially over the years the FCC has
said if a particular aspect of the
marketplace is competitive
then we won't enforce regulations
relating to it but think about the weird
jujitsu that the FCC will have to do in
this context on one hand on a macro
level it's going to have to say that the
broadband internet access market is so
uncompetitive that we need pre-emptive
sweeping regulations along blue lines of
title 2 on the other hand it's going to
have to say the marketplace is
competitive enough that we don't need to
enforce a lot of these different
regulations that's a conceptual problem
that I don't think the the proposal does
a good job of addressing you've talked
about the the proposal as being well
over 300 pages there have been accounts
that it's actually that's mostly
footnotes and addenda and that actually
the rules are about eight or ten pages
is that accurate the rules are eight
pages however the details with respect
to forbearance the regulations from
which we will not be taking action that
is alone as 79 pages
moreover sprinkled throughout the
document there are uncodified rules
rules that won't make it into the Code
of Federal Regulations that people will
have to comply with in the private
sector on top of that there are things
that aren't going to be codified such as
the internet conduct standard where the
FCC will essentially say that it has
carte blanche to decide what kinds of
practices and service plans are
legitimate and which are not and the FCC
tells sort of hints at what factors it
might consider in making that
determination what goes into something
like that where you know you're saying
okay we're the regulators and we're here
now and you got to pay attention to us
but we're not going to actually tell you
what you need to do is that I mean
that's passive-aggressive
you know to the max but I mean I mean is
that a decided strategy to say we want
you to jump but we're not going to tell
you how high I think part of the problem
is that the rules themselves don't give
sufficient guidance to the private
sector regardless of whether they're
public or not and part of the reason why
I want them to be public soon in advance
of the vote is that I think the American
public and particularly the people who'd
be affected by it deserve to see what
regulations are going to be adopted
before they're formally I mean we will
eventually get to read the document but
this this question of the secrecy of the
document you know where somebody I mean
it's maybe this is a bridge too far but
it's almost McCarthyite where you know
we've got these regulations and they're
going to affect you and you'll get to
read them eventually why wouldn't the
FCC just you know put the the document
out into the public when it was
announced that it's going to be voted on
what and what is the history of kind of
the secrecy of rulemaking or
documentation in the FCC and does this
represent a break with that under the
rules only the chairman has the
authority to disclose this document and
he has said both to Congress and to the
public that he's not going to do so and
he has cited the traditional practice of
the FCC which is to not reveal these
proposals until after they are voted on
he's absolutely right that is the
traditional practice how is that a good
practice well I think in this case it
absolutely is not if you look at how
great the public interest is in this
issue the folks who've been advocating
for net neutrality have told us
repeatedly that the Internet is
something unique among the FCC's
responsibilities that four million
people have commented the President
himself has made specific comments about
it so I think if ever we were to make an
exception to the traditional practice
this is it moreover it's not that big of
a leap to say that the FCC should be as
open and transparent as the internet
itself simply publish the rules let the
American people see it and I think they
can make up their own minds and one of
the additional arguments that has been
made is that we need to keep this
document confidential so that various
commissioners can you know suggest
changes etc but by and large I don't
think it's a big surprise as to how the
vote is going to come on February 26 and
you to the extent that that was the
concern I think it's misplace I think we
should just get the document out there
you let the American public haven't
especially to the extent that this
wasn't our proposal in the spring and it
wasn't our proposal in the summer this
came at the insistence essentially of
the white house which as I said to this
day is asking the FCC to implement the
president's plan what will the vote be
what's your prediction
most students err VORs suggested it will
be 3-2 with the three Democrats and the
majority and the two Republicans myself
included in the minority you've I mean
you've criticized the the proposal you
know for not being public will it become
public or when will it become public and
when will there be a kind of commenting
period that you know goes into effect
the FCC will vote on February 26 on this
proposal at that point the document
could be released at any time now given
the sheer breadth of this document as
well as what I would expect to be my
dissent in one of my at least one of my
colleagues dissents then typically the
majority it takes time to respond to our
arguments and there's a back-and-forth
between the majority and the minority
that takes in some cases weeks to iron
out so we could be well into March
before this document gets absolute light
of day there's also a question of you
know what happens next because I'm
assuming that all of the ISPs or at
least some will sue to say this is
another example of the FCC trying to
assert authority or jurisdiction when it
doesn't have any that I mean that's a
foregone conclusion what what does that
suggest that they should have used the
legislative I mean that Congress is the
person or is the body that should be
writing these rules I think so
absolutely when the Verizon versus FCC
decision came out a year ago without
knowing we would end up here I said at
this point the FCC has now been struck
down twice by the courts and in its
attempts to adopt internet regulations
the time has come for us to seek
congressional guidance I mean we are
trying to fit what some consider to be a
square peg of regulation into this round
hole of the Communications Act which as
you pointed out is over eight decades
old so so what role did the White House
play in enforcing this decision I think
the White House changed the landscape
dramatically with the president's
announcement shortly after the midterm
elections that he wanted the FCC to
adopt title 2 regulations and said and
it's still on his website I asked the
FCC to implement
plan and now the FCC is technically an
independent agency right it is and so
husband does that cross any lines or and
is that is it different is it a break
with past protocols of the president
kind of demanding certain things it is a
break in my experience I've served under
a number of different chairman during
administration's of Republican and
Democratic affiliation I've never seen
anything as high-profile as this there
have been other examples of presidents
weighing in with a letter or phone call
that kind of thing but you know splashy
YouTube video website with very specific
prescriptions as to what this agency
should do followed by the agency
suddenly changing course from where it
was to mimic the president's plan
I think suggest that this independence
that the Independence of the agency has
been compromised to some extent how will
we know if title 2 is successful say 10
15 20 years now I think we'll have to
use as objective metric as we can to
measure such things as broadband
availability especially in areas of this
country that are harder to serve I think
we'll have to look at prices to see
whether they've increased or not and
this plan in particular opens the door
to billions of dollars in new fees being
added to people's broadband bills why
does it do that because if you look at
your phone bill you'll see in line item
that says Universal service fee that
applies only to your voice service right
now by treating broadband internet
access as essentially telephone service
it the FCC explicitly opens the door in
this document to the assessment of
universal service fees on the federal
and state level now I'm assuming that
also you know the proponents are saying
no that's part of the forbearance we
won't actually insist on that so I mean
is that accurate or is it just that the
problem is that there are few cases
where the government grants itself power
and then doesn't eventually start
exercising it if you were able to see
this document which you are not you
would see that it explicitly says that
in a few months we are expected we the
FCC are expected to get a recommendation
on how to consider broadband for
purposes of this Universal Service Fund
fee program given the trajectory of the
Universal Service Fund policies from the
Lifeline program to what is called a
rate etc the agency is spending billions
of dollars and is looking to expand it
even further
it's impossible for us to spend money
from the Universal Service Fund on these
programs without including contributions
from the providers the incest
essentially fees based on broadband
connections and there has wireless voice
has been regulated under title 2 for
some time damn right
wireless voice has white data has now
but is there it does wireless voice give
us any indication of you know whether or
not title 2 will be a real heavy
millstone or does it does it show that
you know being regulated under title 2
reduces or retards innovation or what's
experienced there wireless voice if you
look at the data pre prior to the
introduction of the smartphone wireless
voice essentially was a commodity that
you didn't you didn't see a lot of
innovation that's based a lot of
investment for obvious reasons it's you
know not something that carriers we're
spending a lot of time thinking about
and investing in but once mobile data
you started to explode with the
introduction of the iPhone in 2007 all
of a sudden you saw carriers scrambling
to upgrade their networks spend more
money on spectrum to deliver some of
those high bandwidth applications and so
forth and so this argument that wireless
voice having been regulated as title 2
has been a success and so we can do the
same for mobile data is absolute
subsidiaries as they want a free and
open Internet and by that generally what
you know what are the points of
agreement and then when does it get
fuzzy
I think former chairman Powell put it
best when he said in 2004 that there
were four basic internet freedoms that
he thought everyone should agree with
the freedom to access lawful content of
one's choice the freedom to access
applications that don't harm the network
the freedom to attach devices to the
network and the freedom to get
information about your service plan
everybody agrees on that or virtually
everybody I certainly do but the
question is how do we operationalize
that and in my view the federal
government is a pretty poor arbiter of
what is reasonable and what is not and
it's exceptionally poor when it comes to
may have you know having a track record
of promoting innovation and investment
in broadband networks that's something
the private sector has done a remarkable
job on its own what are the instances
that net neutrality proponents point to
I can point to where ISPs have
or other network operators have actually
abrogated those open net principles
they're scattered examples that people
often cite in ISP no one's ever heard of
called Madison River almost a decade ago
some have targeted metro pcs which was
acquired by t-mobile
in crime was yeah Chuck a little bit
about that because that's a fascinating
example it's a metro pcs of course
upstart competitor had virtually no
market no parking power to speak of
compared to the big carriers wanted make
a splash in the marketplace and so it
offered its consumers virtually
unlimited data plans for $40 as you
could stream YouTube for example without
accounting against your data cap all for
40 bucks and net neutrality and and but
it was basically you could only stream
YouTube videos right I mean the rest of
the web was you really couldn't get on
it exactly and so critics called it a
net neutrality violation said that this
is a walled garden that was bad for
consumers and it is telling that they
didn't go after one of the major
incumbents that now they complained
about vociferously they went after an
upstart competitor so it's basically
it's somebody who was saying okay we're
going to give you something for we're
going to give you less for less but if
you want it you can have you either have
to eat it an all-you-can-eat restaurant
or you don't get to eat it all right I
mean that's that's the idea of net
neutrality essentially yeah what do you
think are the main drivers behind that
neutrality because I mean from from my
perspective when I look at things from a
kind of Public Choice economics idea
what I what I tend to see are companies
like Netflix you know Amazon to a
certain degree Google eBay other players
who are very big and have done very well
with the way that the internet works now
and they kind of want to freeze
everything in place and this to me it's
it seems a lot like the robber barons
who were you know when when railroads
were starting to be regulated they were
like great let's regulate things and fix
our market shares or our market
positions is that wrong to think of it
in those terms I certainly think there
are particular companies that might see
strategic advantage and having the FCC
inject itself for the first time into
the nuts and bolts of the Internet's
operation I mean for example regulating
the rates and terms on which is PS and
edged providers have to interconnect
that's something that if you're not
getting a
you think is a good deal through private
commercial agreements might be helpful
to have an FCC backstop I think there
are a lot of other people smaller
entrepreneurs and innovators that we
hear from that are worried that ISPs
might end up acting as gatekeepers and
keeping their content off the web and
while I understand their concern are
nonetheless think that number one there
is no existing as I said a systemic
example of that but number two to the
sent there were the way to solve that is
through case-by-case adjudication using
the antitrust laws or Federal Trade
Commission Authority or even FCC
authority to the extent we have it it is
not imposing title 2 regulations which
ultimately and ironically we're going to
limit the limit the progress of this
online platform I mean I think all these
startups and innovators are based here
for a reason is because we have the best
Internet infrastructure in the world but
that network network doesn't have to
exist people don't have to invest in it
and ultimately this could be
counterproductive for them - you've
you've called that Netflix in particular
which has probably been the most vocal
proponent of net neutrality and of title
to regulation as well they came up or
they apparently have a system where the
way that they code some of their streams
they gain an advantage on existing
networks by the way that they code it
that they're essentially they've created
a fast lane on today's internet why
would that be wrong so to be clear I
don't think that Netflix should be
subject to regulation but when it came
to this question
we got an allegation or we heard an
allegation in the fall from people who
are pushing open video standards
everyone from ISPs to level 3 and
limelight and the like and they wanted
to create a system in which essentially
traffic would be recognized as being
video traffic and then you could
optimize the network to deliver it more
efficiently better experience for the
end-user Netflix we heard was encrypting
some of that traffic to make it
difficult if not impossible for that
traffic to be recognized as video
traffic and so I simply asked them
what's the gist of your response to
these allegations in particular
allegations that they done encryption
selectively and they had picked in
particular encryption against the ISPs
that we're using open video standards
before encryption using encryption again
so that they were kind of sliding by
with
having to stay in the same line that all
other video was right exactly and if the
interest is truly in a free and open
Internet then one could make the
argument that you know what the company
is arguing for when it comes to ISP
behavior should apply equally to edge
provider behavior how did they respond
well they responded that they deployed
encryption to preserve the privacy of
their customers they didn't deploy it
selectively and that none any case there
wasn't any ongoing FCC proceedings so
there wasn't really any reason for them
to respond Netflix was also involved in
a kind of large battle it's not quite
net neutrality but it's peering where
they they were saying basically that
Comcast in particular and a couple of
other large ISPs that customers were
suffering through extended buffering
times where the quality of the stream
and the reliability wasn't so good the
the ISP said look you know Netflix is
generating a huge amount of traffic and
we need to build out our network in
order to handle this traffic and
prioritize it and Comcast in particular
they they have a new deal with Netflix
where Netflix basically pays them more
so that they get a faster pipe into the
into the ISP is that is that the way the
system should work is that it is that a
good outcome is that a bad outcome what
do you think so from a procedural
standpoint neither of those parties ever
filed a formal complaint with us so we
don't have you know what you might
consider objective evidence from the
parties as to what exactly the
nitty-gritty of the situation was so all
I can say is based on what I've read in
the press but that said I think the
nature of the dispute illustrates the
folly of involving the government in
refereeing some of those disputes in
real-time we simply don't have the
ability to determine you know whether
who is right and who is wrong I don't
think even if we had the legal authority
to do it which I don't necessarily think
we do but ultimately by and large if you
look at the end result these
arrangements which have been
commercially reasonable at least
according to both parties given that
they signed it have been good for
consumers and if again if there's some
kind of systemic problem when it comes
to peering and transit in other kinds of
interconnection then I'm certainly
willing to have an open mind about it
but I think in the absence of that
should let the commercial arrangement
work themselves out and and you know
it's funny when you say that you know
it's been good for consumers I guess
that gets lost in a lot of this right
where the you know we're talking about
this as it's a battle between Comcast
and Netflix or this company in that
company but ultimately the measure of
all kind of economic regulation and
certainly an antitrust type of law is
how it affects the consumer and you know
that Netflix has to pay more to deliver
its service or the ISP has to eat more
costs that's not the same thing as
saying the customer is in a bad position
exactly and I'm an antitrust lawyer by
training and that's why I view
everything through the prism of consumer
welfare and that's why I find it amusing
when some of that my critics say that oh
you're just shilling for the big ISPs or
looking at for big business at the end
of the day my concern my sole concern is
what is going to deliver a better
consumer experience in the digital age
and I truly believe that removing some
of these regulations that are impeding
ip-based investment and getting rid of
some of these antiquated regulations is
the best way to promote competition
promote consumer welfare not these over
the top you know 80 year old regulations
that have been proven not to work
Mark Cuban recently said that you know
come out at a tech conference he said
come on getting letting the FCC do title
2 or net neutrality rules the government
will [ __ ] everything up do you agree
with that well as an FCC regular I
certainly can to say that I agree with
his use of one of the seven dirty words
but I will say however is it the gist of
his sentiment is actually absolutely
right I mean do you trust the federal
government to make the internet
ecosystem more vibrant than it is today
can you think of any regulated utility
like The Electric Company or Water
Company that is as innovative as the
Internet I mean I think what he what
Marc Andreessen who developed of course
the first netscape browser what hina
other entrepreneurs are seeing is that
this is something that has worked really
well and there's no reason for the FCC
to mess it up by inserting itself into
areas where it hasn't been before
you've also been critical of the idea
that if the federal government or the US
government gets involved in the
regulation of our internet what that
that sends a particular message to other
countries that's not not particularly
good explain what you mean by that
I think that also on the international
stage there is an effort at the
International Telecommunications Union
which is a an arm of the United Nations
and another forum for the current model
of Internet governance which has been
multi-stakeholder a decentralized to be
changed and a lot of foreign governments
especially repressive governments would
love nothing more than to have more
direct control over both the
infrastructure of the internet and the
content that rides over those networks
the United States to its credit has
spoken with a single voice against such
efforts but I think that to the extent
that title 2 is the approach we take and
the FCC starts to micromanage the same
nuts and bolts at the a of the network
it becomes harder for us on the
international stage to make that case to
persuade other countries not to go down
the same road and I would note that this
is exactly the same position the Obama
administration itself took in 2009 and
2010 when one of our ambassadors of the
State Department said specifically that
he was concerned that title 2 style
regulation would send a negative message
to repressive governments and would lead
them to block or otherwise degrade
certain kinds of Internet traffic is it
time for us to grow up and just say you
know what the the content regulation
that was put into place for broadcast
you know broadcast material whether it's
right or TV we should just get rid of
that I think that's one of the that's
one of the things we've heard from
people who say that the times have
changed since the days of Pacifica back
in the 70s on the other hand we also
hear from a number of different people
who say that a lot of folks who still
rely on over the air broadcasting count
on that B medium being safe for kids
within that window of time so that's
those are the balancing considerations
we're going to have to figure out but
there's no question that it's one of the
challenging issues that you know
especially given the legal context is
difficult to me um you know also the
other thing that was huge then had to do
with ownership rules and concentration
media concentration you know we have a
company like Comcast with you know that
Comcast and NBC and Time Warner or
merging etc but you don't hear the same
fears really that you did a decade ago
or 20 years ago that two or three
corporations owned all of the media is
there a reason you know have
move past that once and for all or is
there a reason to be worried about say a
company like Comcast you know becoming a
major deliverer of content as well as a
major content provider as well as
politically a huge player I've been very
outspoken in my opposition to the media
ownership rules which in some cases are
remain unaltered since 1975 and I think
that outside of major markets but even
in some of the major markets
you see newspapers shuttering you see
radio stations struggling you see TV
broadcasters finding it more difficult
to do the you know I have a hard leg
work of gathering local news and
distributing it and I think in that
context it's incumbent upon the agency
to modernize its regulations to
recognize that cross ownership has some
virtues if you have a radio station and
a newspaper that can collaborate and
distribute the news over multiple
platforms that makes a lot of financial
sense and it's good for the consumer at
the end of the day and so it's been over
eight years now or almost eight years
since we last looked at this even if
even if the same person let's say
ladybird Johnson owned all the TV
stations at all the radio stations in
Austin Texas you would still be able to
get a wide variety of news absolutely
and I think about my own news
consumption I'm a very active user of
Twitter and I use that more or less as
news curation and so I get a lot of my
news through links that I find on
Twitter especially to reason.com well
thank you here's hoping it stays bright
right but you know talk a little bit
about your kind of ideological genealogy
you know where where do your ideas come
from you're obviously very Pro free
market you mentioned your nan T trust
lawyer by training you're a Republican
appointee by Obama so you know you know
what what are the ideas that motivate
your thinking process in terms of
regulation I think going back to college
in the at Harvard in law school
University of Chicago I was exposed to a
view of the world through the lens of
economics that recognized that when
government is relatively restrained in
terms of its intervention in the economy
there is unbounded possibility for the
consumer or the citizen and that's why
I've been outspoken since I've been at
the FCC in favor of policies that I
think will get the government out of the
equation to the extent necessary to
allow innovation to flourish and I think
there's no question that capitalism
generally speaking has been the greatest
source of human benefit much greater
than any government program that's ever
been designed if you look at how many
people have been lifted out of poverty
through free market ideas it's
tremendous and it's that kind of
innovation I think people often take for
granted because we live naturally in the
moment and so it's hard to see the sweep
of history but I can tell you for people
as old as me I remember 20 years ago
when the internet was at its inception
it was hard to get news it was hard to
tape you know do certain things and we
now take for granted on a smartphone but
now thanks to people in the private
sector taking the risk investing the
capital and being able to count on a
regulatory system that didn't
micromanage them that's delivered
unparalleled reckon so how would you
ever get appointed under Obama I I guess
I slipped through but no I think I was
recommended by senator Mitch McConnell
for one of the Republican positions and
by tradition Senate minority leadership
gets a fair degree of deference and I
was fortunate to get the president's
agreement as well do you have any sense
of what the internet will look like in
20 years my wife sometimes thinks I'm
crazy when they say this but it's not
inconceivable that we would see a future
in which people have chips embedded in
their arms which contain all sorts of
information that they're able to connect
wirelessly using those chips to all
kinds of services and applications from
health care to e-commerce the car is
going to be incredibly connected in ways
that might obviate the need for active
management of the car I think there the
internet of things in short is going to
be tremendous and I think that's
something as both as a consumer and as a
former commissioner I guess I'll be at
that time I can't wait to see we'll
leave it there thanks so much for
talking to us we've been talking with G
PI of the FCC for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you